for the first time we were hearing from
race car driver kyle larson
following his highly publicized
suspension from nascar
back in april larson was fired from his
racing team
for using a racial slur during a public
virtual racing event
in his first tv interview larson speaks
with cbs news special correspondent
james brown
about race in america those he has hurt
and why he is hoping for a second chance
i know dee down i'm not a racist i said
a racist word
and i can fully understand why people
would label me a racist
kyle larson the 28 year old six-time
nascar winner
is one of the sport's rising stars but
back in april of this year
larson was heard using the n-word while
speaking on headset during a virtual
racing event
you can't hear me hey
kyle you're talking to everyone but what
prompted you
calling your friend who is white who was
a spotter for you
why did you call him the n-word i had
raced with him
in australia and and you know the group
that we were with kind of used the word
casually as a as a greeting you know i
didn't use it in a way to
you know degrade or or insult anyone
now when you say that it's kind of a
term of endearment or it wasn't meant to
be offensive
how is it that it's in use and no matter
what the circle
and people don't take offense at it you
know it's not my word to use
i need to get it out of my vocabulary
and i have larson's world
quickly unraveled he was fired from his
racing team
lost his sponsors and suspended
indefinitely from nascar
what does the word mean to you what did
it mean to you then
what does it mean to you now i guess i
didn't think of of
how it took african-americans and and
probably in their thoughts
took them back to you know with slavery
and things like that and injustice and
stuff that they have had to work
you're so hard to overcome okay this is
the cow that i know
this is the kyle who said this now which
one is real
michelle and anthony martin are the
co-founders of philadelphia's urban
youth racing school
an organization that connects young
people of color
with the racing industry larson has been
involved with the program for years
as divisive as the rhetoric is at the
public level in the square if you will
michelle many people wouldn't step up
you and your husband
to be supportive in a situation like
this
at a time like this why were you
supporting kyle larson
publicly i had the opportunity to
meet with kyle face to face after it
happened
one of the things in looking in his eyes
for the sincerity was
are you sorry that you got caught
or are you really sorry that this
happened
with our very first conversation post
the n-word situation was the fact that
he wanted to learn it was it was very
emotional because i look up to him a lot
josier fisher knows kyle larson well the
18 year old mechanical engineering
student connected with larson during his
time at the racing school
and the two met face to face this summer
to talk about what happened
when it happened and it just had me
thinking like as a african-american male
a lot of people in america see me as
that word and like for
somebody like him to say that it was
like nothing nothing less than
heartbreaking
and for him to like speak to me it gave
me more reassurance that
i can still look up to him and trust him
you said when most people in america
probably look at you
as being that n-word yes
you wanted to make sure that he wasn't
thinking the same thing about you
yes why should anyone believe
that there's been a significant and real
change in your heart i understand you
know people who might not know me
if they might not believe it or think
i'm just checking the box
and you know i feel like i've definitely
grown more in these last you know six
months than i have in
the 28 years i've been alive had you
given serious thought to
if racing with nascar were to not be in
your future
would that be too steep a price to pay
for you i don't think it would be
too steep of a price to pay you know
what i said was extremely hurtful and
i would fully understand if i was never
allowed to race another nascar race
again but i hope you know i will get
that opportunity to race
with them with that platform i think i
could you know
do some good things james you know i
have to say i appreciate his
apology i also appreciate the fact that
he sat down with you
last time i checked you are a black man
and he's looking at you face to face
with a word that's very hurtful and it
did not seem to be an awkward
conversation
between the two of you
gail he really has owned the problem
he's embraced it he's looking to make
positive changes
uh look i discern the young man's heart
yeah and um
i think he's the real deal go ahead gail
he said he's gone through a
rehabilitation process over the last six
months
what does that mean exactly what does
that include and what do you make of
that
so uh he's gone through sensitivity
training he's gone through diversity
inclusion training he's gone down to the
legacy museum
uh a memorial in montgomery alabama look
and he's done all of this
and a lot more out of the public
spotlight sitting down with people like
jackie joyner kersey
uh the former executive with def jam
kevin lyles he's made all the right
moves at the end of the day it's whether
or not there's a heart change i discern
it
because if people are doubting whether
or not he should get reinstated which is
up to nascar the fact of the matter is
we know people cannot consistently
perform
in a manner that is inconsistent with
who they really are
his body of work suggests that he's
really the real deal
all right second chances you know we
live in a canceled culture it's good to
see that he's making an effort
thank you very much james brown always
good to see you